hello everyone how are you
that's natural Libre
you know that how are you it's the next
[Music]
welcome to another month bottom slash
food review and we got a special treat
for you today
today we are going to be reviewing slash
eating slash mukbang me in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] some chicken wings with a
capital H now I've only been here once
[ __ ] shake your head now I've only
been here one time before but in that
one time it done grabbed me by the heart
and my testicles and tied it into a
little bow because this place my friends
to me has the best Korean chicken wings
hands down now when you walk into this
restaurant just know don't expect too
much from it in terms of like oh my god
it's not as cute as other places and the
place has a lot of like random stuff in
there like boba and some noodles now
personally that's not what I go there
for it might be good who knows but [ __ ]
that [ __ ] just get the chicken wings if
that's what you want we are going to be
reviewing three of their flavors that
they had there and I'm telling you right
now when I ate that [ __ ] and I crunched
on that [ __ ] and done sent me to
another universe so so why keep you
waiting let's get into this and let's
chomp on these damn wings
I like your munch on a lesbians buzzing
that was unnecessary it wasn't it let's
let's leave that out oh my god do you
look do you see do you want biggest
smell to get taste this right here my
friends is Korean chicken wings now
right off the bat when you're looking at
this it already doesn't look like
American chicken wings and let me just
give you a breakdown about what you're
gonna be biting into now typically with
Korean chicken wings you are gonna get
like a cabbage slaw on the side the
sauce that you see here made for the
slaw the sauces for the chicken are all
in-house house-made all that [ __ ] is
made from scratch I talked to the lady I
[ __ ] know and that's what I like
about the place she perfected her own
sauces she's very proud of it to the
point where she was just talking about
she was like in comparison to other
restaurants and their chicken wings
people always say that herds are the
best and if she's proud enough to say
that I am willing to try it than when I
ate it it was [ __ ] delicious so let's
bite into this and I'm gonna talk a
little bit more about the chicken wings
as I do [ __ ]
oh man that's what's up hold on second
second now with every Korean chicken
wing dish you are also going to get a
side of this right here this is their
pickled radish that's gonna be in a rice
vinegar and sugar and you get this nice
sweet acidic tangy crunch now let's wait
for this crunch oh yeah
oh yeah you know why I demamp you should
be really proud of this off because this
is out of this world oh my god
this right here cousin this right here
is a [ __ ]
the main difference that you're gonna
have with these chicken wings it's what
the chicken is actually coated with I
can tell right off the bat right when
I've been into it and the texture of
what's on it
it's gonna be potato starch it's what I
use with my chicken wings potato starch
in comparison the corn starch is going
to be different in the sense that it has
more protein when you have more protein
in that flour it Browns a lot better oh
then you get this you know if you ate
chicken wings by the way you've got to
eat all those little nubs and [ __ ] too
that's that good [ __ ] if you ain't
eating chicken wings like that chop off
your feet do you know what they say
Asian people your chicken wings like
this is an archeological dig to this
[ __ ] look like a fossil when I'm
done today pretty sure a lot of vegans
are looking at this and they're like you
[ __ ] monster you're chewing on the
leg of a chicken I know what I'm doing
let's put a bit of dressing for that
slaw
on it like such ah hmm it's like a
Thousand Island of some sort just
definitely ketchup in there
delicious [ __ ] whip you need a little
cabbage a sloth some fiber some vitamins
to make you feel good about the [ __ ]
when you're eating before we move on let
me just have one more wing oh man
definitely garlic in here definitely
gochujang which is that red pepper paste
and then you are honey or your tea down
which is like corn syrup
so damn good so good before I eat this
whole goddamn plate let's move on to the
next one up next we have they're very
famous soy garlic now if you've seen my
previous mukbang before I made my own
soy garlic chicken wings so I'm trying
to see if they're soy garlic is better
than the one that I have I never had
this well garlic one purse first about
the upholstery work were specifically
because I didn't want to eat something
that was better than mine and then my
self-esteem dropped so without further
ado let's give this a go we don't go for
that little drumstick though you just
stop looking at me like that
[ __ ] tonight what not good
Oh got a little heat to it it might be
better than mine oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you know women is good when you don't
even give it a second for you to breathe
in between bites oh man you know I like
about them too they're not using monster
wings you know I mean some other places
that I go to these huge [ __ ]
pterodactyl chicken wings I'd hate that
[ __ ]
it's too much I want a little bit of
meat a little bit of crust in a bit of
bit of crunch oh man a little spicy Fox
with a heavy I need to cool it down with
a DICOM mmm it resets your button odor
this baby wing this ain't even a real
wing oh it's kind of burning my tongue a
little bit Oh
ah a good chicken wing is all about that
crunch has wings recently at Domino's
yeah [ __ ] those wings [ __ ] disgusting
huh
floppy skin generic ass sauce
why even search it like that Domino's
huh what you doing hmm
it's burning my tongue [ __ ] chica ha
ha ha
I need some slaw to cool this down
well mm-hmm mm-hmm what's the technique
that you guys have when you eat your
chicken wings I saw one dude do it like
this hold on a second was it you just
now when you take it and you do a little
twisty like this and you pop this bone
out right laughs that you have one bone
to go through like so Oh burned in my
mouth
Oh what
but I can't stop eating it Oh Korean
people like chicken fried chicken and
beer and watermelon more than anybody
else is his brother ah I'm bad of a
black person on that [ __ ] but every
single like Korean event that I've had
or been to we always had sliced
watermelon no matter what every time we
had like a party there was always
chicken wings and every time we go out
we always drink beer so I don't know if
that could be truly attributed to the
black American culture but if it is then
we have something in common and that's
what I'm talking about we don't like
debt you know what that's a sign from
God that means I hold all my I hold on a
second what did I just do right now what
did I just do right now
this right here is a boneless chicken
wing look Wow wake up wake up wake up
it's the first of the month
the last piece to this [ __ ]
puzzle is my favorite favorite flavor of
all the honey butter glaze honey butter
do you understand what I just told you
right now honey butter sound like a
lotion you want to put on your ass
cheeks right before you [ __ ] and when I
had this chicken wing I'll tell you this
I was said straight to heaven I just
talked to Jesus Christ I said Jesus I
said Jesus how you go create this here
fault he said my child I created to fold
you and I done went to Memphis stop
believes himself and I said you ain't
gonna touch my chicken wings and I don't
ain't this [ __ ] like this whoo
look at that [ __ ] hang like a little Pew
from a dingleberry oh man I'll tell you
this when you a chicken will you make
you do this that's when you know it's
good sweet savory toffee
with garlic oh man mmm I like food man I
don't know what it is about it I know
food don't make me look cute but it make
me feel cute you know I'm saying mmm oh
[ __ ] what you ladies think I got a
girlfriend
[ __ ] y'all I'm kidding
he was cool about women nowadays y'all
better than TV now TV and ads they don't
influence you like you used to now y'all
know to look on the inside
that's like Mary oh she looked past all
this [ __ ] and she said you know what
that's a handsome man in between those
clogged arteries mm-hmm if there was one
wing that you wanted to get here and you
liked that sweet savory plate you have
to get the honey butter this is the [ __ ]
this is not a sponsored video this is
just how much I love them knock that top
off take that bone yawn saying ooh rip
that [ __ ] out like oh this hot just
like this
it's like you've been eating chicken
wings your whole life right and you have
an expectation of what you think chicken
wings are supposed to be like did you
have this and you're like what the [ __ ]
what is this that's like people maybe
who used to be a theist and they said
you know what Jesus didn't exist and
then Jesus came down and stepped on
their [ __ ] front toes like [ __ ] I am
here that is the experience that you're
gonna get with this [ __ ] mmm I
don't know I got this board crunchy
sweet delicious puts you into a better
place
that's what food should do for you put
you into a better place you failed your
exam go get some food your girls are
done to go get some food chicken wings
don't yell oh god they don't yell at you
dangling glory this will be waiting for
you at home this right here this is
gonna be waiting for you you ready for
that [ __ ] yeah you ready for that life
dear God I'd like to thank you for this
meal I'd like to thank you for the fact
that you gave me a big enough belly
where I could eat anything that I want
and we [ __ ] and that concludes this food
review / Bhagavan - you already know
people how much I love food if there's
another joy you want me to try that I
haven't tried that we could review that
[ __ ] together let me know in the
comments below and we gonna get it
popping and cracking baby I gotta go
work out after this because oh [ __ ]
deliciousness comes with the cost -
Mantid it if I didn't have very old what
any of you girls date me because
seriously
you